hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show we're here after
our show with Philip Bloom and we had
our wonderful co-host AJ rickard Epstein
yes cinematographer here in LA and he's
from Ohio and he told us earlier that
when you were about 21 you decided to
make your own feature after making
several shorts for years and that you
went back to Ohio shot the feature but
now you work as a cinematographer so
talk about the reasons why you decide to
help other people make their films as
opposed to making your own okay um
actually wasn't my original decision I
just kind of got it's just beard off on
this path I had several friends and
colleagues asked me to shoot their
projects for them and I just kind of I'd
never had the experience of actually
focusing only on the camera and I found
it actually a freeing experience because
I'm not filmmaking I was doing
everything myself and using all parts of
my brain for that and you know it was it
was actually like almost I don't know it
was really easy to shoot only just
camera work stuff because I was so used
to doing everything myself so I guess
after a couple experiences with that I
realized that if I really put my mind to
this I could get pretty specialized in
this area if I let you know did my best
to learn more and experience more in
this this field so I guess I just
pursued after a couple i did a feature
film called Eastern college which we
shot the following summer for my film
also back in Ohio
friend Jimmy Flynn who i co-wrote my
film with and that experience got me a
couple other gigs as a cemetery fur with
director Larry blend Meyer who does cult
comedy stuff he was pretty well known
for her phone called the lost skeleton
of cadavra and I was fortunate enough to
shoot the sequel to that as well as his
follow-up film the dark and stormy night
and that was my biggest film as a
cinematographer at that point it was
about a 19 I'll budget a little more
than that actually and a huge set bill
the production designer from army of
darkness was involved and I really got a
sense of working with professional gear
and professional crew and zeroing in on
just the camera work and you know
working with a directory with making his
vision come true so from that point
forward I just kind of stuck with it I
mean the more you do on something the
most time he's found something the more
stuff comes your way from that that
venture usually my own experience and I
guess I really like shooting stuff so
it's not it's not like I pursued that as
my career but because I love it it's
natural to me so I go for it and you
know I guess all this time I've kind of
been still a filmmaker and just guys but
you know I've been able to learn so much
more about the technical aspects of the
filmmaking without having the
responsibility of an entire film on our
shoulders I can I can do what I do best
behind the camera without without having
to live with a movie for
for two years however long it takes
sometimes for people for a director to
push the film through it from beginning
to end so I come in you know close to
the production process with them there
throughout production then I kind of go
and go to something else whereas the
directors in the editing room the
director is still trying to push
promotion and get it distributed just a
lot more stuff going on with that role
rather than the cemetery for you kind of
freed up a little bit more in your time
this is a divvied up a little bit easier
so I'm able to do more projects in a
shorter amount of time which is kind of
what I'm focusing on now and just
getting better as fast as I can doing as
much as I can in a short amount of time
as possible and just filling up my time
with with knowledge knowledge seeking
experiences and and and just kind of
developing my style and learning about
aspects of filming that I didn't know
before when i first was doing about
myself so that way when I actually do my
next film it will be a much more
informed project a little more
well-rounded and I'll be able to make
decisions based on all this previous
experience and speaking of the speed in
between projects that you mentioned when
we were in the lobby you talked briefly
about how one of the things that you
think maybe holds some filmmakers back
is there sort of time in between
projects that maybe they hold on to one
kind of pet project too long and it
actually hinders their career can you
touch on that a little bit yeah I mean
I'm just speaking from my own personal
experience so this may not be the case
for some folks but I found that when i
did my film and i spent a significant
amount of time promoting and trying to
get it out there and you know there was
some success to that but i personally
have an appetite for more and the next
thing so i find that what brings more
work and more progress my way is by
doing the next
by getting better and moving on you
don't have to divorce yourself
completely from a project that you've
done but I just would if I'm finishing
the project chances are I'm already
thinking about the next one or working
on the next one even sometimes while I'm
shooting that project so you know it's
it's not I guess my way of life is to
overlap things a little bit and I find
that it brings progress speed heater and
a little more it keeps you more involved
and it's kind of like playing a
professional sport or something where
you have to practice all the time this
allows me to practice in different ways
all the time i'm being challenged in
different parts of my cinematography
brain and all the time shooting
different types of projects for
different types of people which is
another key aspect to it dealing with
different types of people is also a big
thing you're in the leadership position
like cemetery fur you have to be able to
medium you know to manage your time and
to delegate things and to be able to you
know deal with political issues and
stuff like that so all these things I am
learning as i do projects and you get
better by learning and the more you
learn the better you get so it just
makes sense to me to try to compress
time a little bit i'm looking forward
more than i'm looking better sometimes
when i do look backward I'm like whoa
it's crazy or I maybe should have
thoughts about something a little bit
more but I find that it's easier to just
move forward and and I get better as a
person in it as if so Murtagh referred
by moving forward and not thinking so
much about the past as often one thing I
want to ask you was what do you do in
the situation why are you working with a
director and the director wants a
certain shot and you know that it would
actually be better another way how do
you finesse that do you go with what
they say or do you try and put your own
I don't know say agenda but your own
feelings about the shot in and
make that smooth transition um well the
way I see it if I'm working for a
director chances are they thought about
this project a lot more than I have and
they had probably have a really good
reason for why they want this for
certain thing and maybe I'm not seeing
that right then so I try to have an open
mind like that where I'm like okay we'll
do it this way even though it may not be
what instinctually worked for me let's
make it work for you and we'll make your
project work that's my job as a
cinematographer to try to make the
director's vision happen whether or not
I feel it's my vision that's not the
issue it's their vision I'm trying to
make em if I can contribute to that and
bring my sense of style and my sense of
just filmmaking quality to the to the
piece then then that's great and a lot
of times that that's how it works with
my relationship with directors is on
collaborate with them long before we
start shooting just talk about what
needs to be done and how it should look
what type of style we should be doing
that that kind of ends up dissolving any
problems before we get on set but if it
does happen to be a film work or project
problem working with a director that I
haven't worked with before or haven't
had any previous production of
pre-production stuff with I kind of I
kind of give them the benefit of that
because they know more about the project
and I do as though in some cases there's
things that are you know definitely
wrong they should be doing but you know
in that case you just can all you can do
is describe the reason why behind it to
them and if they still choose to do it
that way that's fun third out that's
their project do it do
for them all right i mean i just add one
thing you don't have to just sometimes
it's possible to do it many ways like
you can do a few tapes of different ways
so that way they have choices in the
editing room and if you can convince the
director to do that in a situation where
you feel like what they're doing is
completely wrong which doesn't happen
very often but if it does I just try to
strongly suggest that we shoot a couple
different ways so that they have choices
in the editing room and that is good
overall anyways I mean just to have
other options in the editing room
because you sometimes run into problems
outside of technical stuff it could be
performance wise it could be script
why's it can be you don't get a chance
to shoot this one scene so you have to
change the story around like having an
ability and flexibility in post is
another part of my job trying
Oh